[Music]
our serious real food looks at new ways
food is being grown and prepared this
morning we focus on the expanding veggie
movement more than 22 million American
adults today eat mostly or strictly
vegetarian or vegan farmers markets have
grown steadily since 2004 rising to more
than eight thousand veggies are now
taking a leading role in restaurants
nationwide Jamie wax is at a vegetable
garden on a barge in the Bronx New York
to see what's growing Jamie good morning
good morning
we're here at Swale that barge floating
around New York City this summer here
the public is encouraged to forage for
their own vegetables it's providing
access to the fresh ingredients that are
part of the changing way we eat and
cauliflower peas beets these stalwart
vegetables are no longer the sad side
dish on the dinner plate hidden under a
napkin left uneaten by generations of
American kids now there are the stars
first iceberg is beautiful with dozens
of restaurants around the world
I bet and several Michelin stars
internationally renowned chef
jean-georges Vongerichten knows the best
ingredients make the best food when you
see a market like this you don't need
anything else it's true on a recent tour
the fresh produce stands at New York
City's Union Square Green Market can
kale survive its trendiness do you think
kale was forever quite off you can cook
it you can save the world he introduced
us to the familiar what is my favorite
this is new galley the more unusual not
the first time I've tasted a the
flowering part of the watercraft
so peppery it is spicy and even the
completely unknown those are fiddlehead
ferns inspired by the abundance and
variety of vegetables somebody told me
last night we need more mushroom dishes
on a menu
longer ishtam recently opened his first
vegetarian restaurant at the 13abc v
just around the corner you can really
treat a mushroom exact
his official visit me those are the
shiitake we bought of the market this
morning you have a plate I guess he's
very satisfying you know that is
delicious there's any piece of fish for
me I've ever had any piece of meat with
vegetables you have to push a little
harder because people say oh it's just a
piece of vegetable adding flavors and
layers chefs and restaurants across the
country and at all price points are
making veggies the star of the plate
whether vegan vegetarian or vegetable
forward it's now about celebrating
vegetables not trying to replace meat we
went from being focused on nose to tail
eating to now thinking about roots of
stem eating we met food & wine editor
Neelu Mitama that the michelin-starred
vegetarian restaurant mix in New York
City vegetable forward cooking is not
necessarily vegetarian cooking but it's
really looking at vegetables as the
focal point of a meal and the rest as
additional players written a to romaine
right after that in Chicago chef Dan
Snowden and a self-styled vegetable
affectionate restaurant bad hunter put
down roots late last year in the city's
Meatpacking District we just love our
vegetables here but we also like me
Snowden says he's feeding the appetites
of a health and environment focused
public that is clamoring for vegetable
based meals where meat is a side dish a
garnish or even absent the educated
diner wants to know where their food is
coming from and why and how we really
abide by that philosophy of using
produce and meats as conscious as we can
some folks have said Millennials have a
part in this trend Millennials are
pushing the envelope for us all they are
engaged they care
do you see people come in to this
restaurant who are skeptical who don't
think they're gonna enjoy it
I sing breakfast no lunch no dinner a
little bit I wasn't nervous about dinner
because you know you think about a
little more substantial meat fish
restaurant so we replace it by dishes
like this whole cauliflower and while
not everyone is ready to spend big money
on a vegetable on trend more hungry
diners are turning up for it tapes is
that fun for you as a chef to make
converts of people who don't believe in
this kind of cooking absolutely
absolutely the challenge is what we do
I think plants on vegetables can be
their way of the future and it takes two
weeks to grow a radish text to three
years to raise a cow it's nothing the
diets can be better for anybody and
that's just fine with you it's fine with
me there we go cookbooks are also being
dominated by vegetables this season with
healthy recipes for the home cook so
this really does appear to be a movement
happening at all levels
Gail all right Jamie this is so weird I
was just there Saturday I brought the
leftover spaghetti squash that's what
I'm having for lunch today
that sounds totally I know sweetie right
at home yeah yes I'm that guy I want to
take this and the avocado lettuce offer
you next when I go out to dinner they
say you want to take this with you I've
just said nope you I'm a great date
every kale for lunch tomorrow